le visage impassible le président de
l'autorité palestinienne s'installe à la
table du conseil de sécurité
sans aucune surprise mahmoud abbas
réitère son rejet du plan de paix
américain
un projet qui selon lui entérinerait
l'annexion des territoires palestiniens
par israël
[Musique]
je suis venu vous voir au nom de 13
millions de palestiniens pour appeler à
une paix juste
c'est tout je suis venue devant vous
aujourd'hui
mesdames et messieurs pour réaffirmer la
position palestinienne qui rejette la
proposition israélo américaine de son
côté israël réaffirme sa position pour
l'état hébreu aucune paix n'est possible
tant que les palestiniens ne changeront
pas de dirigeant abbas a beaucoup
d'expérience dans l'art du double
discours
il vient ici à l'onu il prétend
s'engager pour la paix mais il reste
engagé dans l'incitation à la violence
avant de partir abbas à encourager les
palestiniens à se révolter et à se
livrer à la violence contre les
israéliens face à cette nouvelle impasse
diplomatique des milliers de
palestiniens ont apporté leur soutien
leurs dirigeants en défilant dans les
rues de ramallah en cisjordanie avec
cette manifestation nous déclarons notre
rejet de ce plan et nous dénonçons le
dernier clou dans le cercueil de la
cause palestinienne
nous espérons que notre président
restera ferme dans ses positions face
aux dirigeants du monde entier car nous
sommes la clé c'est à nous de décider
d'accepter ou non cet accord nous sommes
venus soutenir nos dirigeants politiques
nous disons à ce monde injuste que la
palestine est nôtre depuis la mer
jusqu'à ses rivières et nous disons à
trump songe andrea netanyahu que nous
resterons aussi longtemps qu'il le faut
pour tenter de relancer le processus de
paix mahmoud abbas a demandé aux états
unis de ne plus se poser en seul
médiateur pour la paix au moyen-orient
entre le président de l'autorité
palestinienne souhaite notamment
l'organisation d'une conférence
réunissant etats unis russie union
européenne et onu
la situation pourrait également évoluer
après les prochaines élections
législatives israéliennes qui se
tiendront début mars
[Musique]